[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use
in your everyday life hi i'm dan hayes
and
i'm joined by my co-host dr greg sadler
and today
we're talking about doing a deeper dive
on negative visualization but also
positive visualization and these
are practices that i think some of our
listeners will be
already familiar with if they're into
stoic philosophy and practice
negative visualization is one of the one
of the
keystones you could say right most of
the great sources out there
talk about it but we we want to go a
little bit further into it we've talked
about it on the
show before we've used it as a practice
that we
walk people through at the end but
there's there's so much more to it
that we wanted to discuss it a little
bit more and talk about
how other schools or approaches
have looked at visualization as well
and so to do a really quick recap
of negative visualization at least
within the stoke school and what we've
spoken about before
is a idea of bringing forth the
uh potential outcomes specifically what
would be considered bad outcomes
and um one looking at them
and creating better potential outcomes
by
like thinking through how you could deal
with them as well as
to really realize that these things
themselves
are indifference and they don't have a
value of good or bad
but it's this putting us in these
challenging situations
that we can then more easily practice
our virtue
yeah so that that's a good sort of
thumbnail sketch of it and we're going
to go a little bit deeper into that
a little bit later on in the program but
first we want to talk about
when we bring up this word visualization
it's already got a lot of
baggage associated with it so we wanted
to clarify
what we mean and what we what we don't
mean by that
so the kind of visualization that we're
talking about
is using our capacities and the ones
that
are the most important our imagination
and
memory and also our whatever we want to
call it our will our capacity to choose
because
when we direct our attention to
something or we tell
our imagination hey you know put this up
in front of our
our whatever we want to call it put it
on our mental tv or
you know play it for me we're we're
deciding what to do
and this gets talked a lot about
in philosophy as well as in psychology
and in a lot of religious traditions
where it's been used
and a prime example of this that i just
want to mention but we're not going to
go
into too much because there's probably
not a lot of people listening because
they want to learn about rene descartes
in particular
but if you look at renee descartes
meditations
they're actually designed to do exactly
that
they are having the person
walk through a bunch of things that we
can call
visualizations you know imagine that i
don't actually have a body well that's
that's using your imagination to
try to resolve something or imagine if
there's like an evil demon that
is is totally devoted to deceiving me
and it's just
very powerful what would i actually be
able to to get out of that what
you know that's where the famous
cartesian kojicho comes from so i just
wanted to
bring that up as an example of some
famous philosopher who we don't
usually think about as engaging in
spiritual practices or philosophical
practices
as somebody who really centered his work
around that
and we're also we want to be careful
not to think about visualization as it's
often used in say graphic design
where or in in talking about tech
issues right where we visualize
a process or a project
and we turn it into something like like
a diagram
you could in fact use things like that
and we do
to support the internal visualization
but that's an externalization right
if you come up with a nice uh what do we
call those infographic right
that's a visualization or we talk about
data visualization as well
that's that's cool that's useful but
that's not what we're talking about here
the other thing that we're not talking
about and this is going to lead into a
little bit of a
i think a side discussion we're not
talking about
imagining doing something like playing
basketball well there's studies out
there that
say that they proved that if you like
imagine shooting hoops
you actually get better at shooting
hoops um i'm not quite sure
so sure if that's that's the case or not
um and we're not thinking about like you
know having your best life and putting
together
vision boards or anything like that and
so this is we wanted to
to talk about a few things in particular
that were
were not confusing these practices with
so um the secret you wanted to bring
that up as a particular example right
and so i think you have to tell people
what it is because not everybody's heard
of it
yes this is the secret is one of those
you know
uh kind of under the umbrella of
positive
thinking this idea that uh
you can um create through your mind
on positive outcomes in the real world
by
you know staying positive and focused on
your goals in your mind to
ignore uh self-doubt and criticism
within your mind
and to visualize and concentrate on what
you want
and this will somehow result in you
eventually having it
and so the secret is just one of the a
number of different
uh books that over the years have kind
of had its own different spin
on this idea another one is vincent
peels the power of
positive thinking yeah and
and the secret itself like it's little
tick actually did you have something you
want to talk about vince appeal
no i was just going to say that there
were there were all he was the most
successful
of a whole slew of people who are saying
the same kind of thing
i mean i think every generation has
somebody coming along
and not just somebody but a whole bunch
of people coming along and repackaging
this idea
and what's really different about this
and what we're talking about is the
notion that by like having a positive
attitude
you change reality itself yes
we're not saying that no we're we're
always working with like
how we are going to then eventually
react and
and how our future selves could
potentially react to
the reality of the situation now that
the reality the situation is going to
change around us
to uh fit our whims yeah you know let's
let's pause on that for for
a minute so part of what's wrong with
that idea
is the notion that if i could just get
like my external reality to change
everything would be great and where
we're going with this is
saying no your external reality is
probably going to still suck
but you can change how you react to it
how you think about it
you know you can change yourself that's
that's what ancient philosophy that's
what a lot of religious traditions
that's what
psychology when it's when it's doing its
job well
they they help us to do right they you
know not just to be sort of these
uh either everything's great or
everything's awful and it all depends on
whether i've got you know a couple cars
out front and you know plenty of i don't
know bon bons to snack on a beautiful
person to to be involved with the uh
accolades and and uh you know affection
of those
involved in my profession we could go on
and on right and
the biggest problem with a lot of those
things is that they're
things that are that can be put on the
hedonic cycle as in
you uh you start to lose
the happiness of having them and so
you're like oh look i'll only be happy
once i get a house in a car
and then you have them and then now that
doesn't fulfill you anymore and so it's
like oh i needed another car i need a
better car
and you're always you know striving to
try to get
that next thing and uh
part of a lot of the uh inch
philosophies here are talking about
how you can try to get off of that cycle
you know
again a little bit of a digression but i
think this is
quite interesting given those examples
so if you
think that like getting the most new and
interesting or whatever you want to call
it
model of the car out there is going to
make you happy you're right it's not
going to make you happy
and then you're confronted with a couple
different choices one would be to get
back on
what you're calling the hedonic
treadmill right and just keep grinding
away at it and get a newer car and a
newer car and a newer car and that's not
really going to work
another thing would be to say oh it's
all garbage
let's throw this away you know and and
then usually what people do
when they do that is jump immediately
into pursuing something else right
i'm going to collect us all the comic
books or i'm going to you know
whatever i'll change my romantic life
i'll change my professional life and
it's it's still this
it's still the same hedonic treadmill
what they don't do and what a third
possibility
would be and i think what you know
ancient philosophy
uh when it's understood rightly teaches
us to do is to analyze to say
well why the hell did i think that
getting a car would actually make me
happy what's what's going on with me
you know what are my assumptions and
then you know not to like say oh i need
to immediately throw them away
as soon as you realize how irrational
they are but you keep probing at it why
am i so irrational
why do i why do i you know subject
myself
to these unlikely to work out beliefs
and if you're told at least from a very
young age that these are the things that
you should strive for
sometimes it's very difficult to see
the uh the things you're bringing to the
table
uh with you that's quite true yeah and
that's where it can be quite helpful to
i don't know talk with somebody else or
compare notes or be in a
um a group of some sort where you you
compare your stories and figure out how
not only did you you know i mean odds
are you didn't screw yourself up
until later on somebody else screwed you
screwed you up for you
early on and then you just kind of
repeated it over and over again right uh
so one of the reasons why these i guess
i'd call them charlatans keep on uh
repackaging the same thing is this idea
of a survivorship bias
and when you know the survivorship bias
yeah yeah so uh for example if i
uh have a thousand emails and i send out
uh
to 500 of them uh this stock is going to
go up
and then i send another 500 to to the
other 500
this stock is going to go down and on
the next day it goes
up well i throw out the second half and
i only choose the first half and i
subdivide them and say this other stock
will go up or down
tomorrow and you keep on doing that you
do that for several weeks and all of a
sudden you've got these
this group of like maybe 10 people who
uh
have heard you for several weeks be
absolutely correct over and over and
over again
and so they think that you are like
the the best stock guru there is and
everyone else forgets that you were
wrong well or
you don't even interact with them
there's like oh they got wrong and so
you don't even talk to them anymore and
so
uh with a survivorship bias you hear
these people that
are promoting this idea
and those are the ones that just
happened to
um become successful it wasn't
because of this it was uh
the actual process like oh
you know maybe a thousand people tried
this one person succeeded at whatever
they're trying to do
but that one's the one that you actually
hear about and so you follow what
they're saying
and those will be the testimonials in
the book or
video or whatever it's going to be yeah
you know
that that's actually a that's a great
way to explain how these things
maintain their hold on on so many people
um and you know to go back to to
what we are talking about here then so
you i've used the term spiritual
practices that's something that comes
from this guy pirando who wrote a
you know set of of books devoted to
philosophy as a way of life one of them
is called philosophy as a way of life
but there's a whole bunch of other ones
as well
including a new set of translations out
by the way by uh
really yeah matthew sharp and i forget
who the other
person involved with it was and i only
know because i got sent a copy
and i haven't i haven't read them yet
but i imagine they're going to be quite
interesting
but you know another really great way of
talking about
these practices michel foucault used the
term technologies of the self
i kind of like that because
and i'm not a big like you know let's
let's hack our programming kind of guy i
don't usually use all these tech
metaphors
but i do kind of think that our capacity
to
analyze ourselves oftentimes with help
from others you know saying hey man
you're screwing up
what's wrong with you i've noticed this
about you
and then to use our ability to choose
the thing we call the will
this this capacity for choice to
gradually
change our habits and you know undermine
wrong-headed assumptions replace them
with better assumptions
i think what we are really talking about
here is something like a kind of
technology that allows us to change
ourselves for the better
and the emphasis there is on changing
ourselves
not not just changing some little bit of
ourselves like whether we
you know recite some mantra to ourselves
as we get up in the morning but some
positive thinking thing but but
really working on what makes us tick and
i think one of the questions we do have
to keep on asking ourselves is man why
am i so screwed up
the other thing i'll mention too with
this and we were talking about this
before the show
so going back to things like the secret
um
if you don't get the results that you
want this kind of ties in with the
survivorship bias
the response can always oh you didn't
work the system properly right
oh yeah now what's to keep somebody from
saying that about stoicism
you know that that you know if if things
don't go
well with negative visualization so well
you're not doing it right
is there a difference between that and
the
the guru saying oh you didn't work the
system right i think there is
what do you think it is i guess i would
go to
some of the um the clinical research
done for
like rebt and cbt i'm sorry rational
behavioral therapy and
cognitive behavioral therapy yeah um
and there seems to be a
correlation of strong correlation
between you know benefits of doing this
uh at least in mental states and and
maybe there is
you know at least that's better than oh
you're just not doing it right there is
some studies to back that up
that's that's a good one i would also
say that the stoics
and some of the other groups that we're
going to talk about can actually say
well
you didn't just not do it right here's
what you
missed out on here's why it turns out
that way
that's part of what it means to have
something like a technology you can say
this this thing over here isn't doing
its job or you you forgot to add this
part
here you know and so um
i unlike you i have no problem using
technology metaphors because that's kind
of the world that i live in well of
course
yeah but
i was thinking about this and maybe a um
a different translation instead of
technologies but like
technique or you know uh technology
comes from the what the the greek
protector of
um correct well uh it comes from techne
right which means a way of being able to
produce something so like pottery is a
techne and medicine is a technique and
so is rhetoric by the way
and so i was thinking along the lines of
maybe instead of having the like the
really mechanical connotations of it but
bring it back to the techne of the self
and that might be a better way for you
to visualize that without being pushed
away by that technology
another translation well two other
translations that they use in english
for techne
are craft which is closer to
um you know the technology aspect of it
but also art they translated as art so
maybe
you know when we talk about something
being more of an art than a science
maybe that's kind of along those lines
so we were
um do we want to go let's talk about
more stoics yeah
yeah so there's a lot of fancy latin
names that people use
and i mean if you want to use latin to
sound cool that that's perfectly fine
you can call it you know premeditation
malorum
which just means you know thinking about
bad things in advance
or sometimes it gets called memento mori
which is a little bit more specific
because mori is death right
so being mindful of of death which you
know
a lot of people are worried about death
so that kind of that would be like
your far end of your negative
visualizations
well yeah i mean if you're thinking
about your own death which is yeah
kind of difficult to picture um if
you're really trying to do it right
you're not just like being like tom
sawyer
uh yeah do you remember that scene oh
yeah
that's a great scene
then shows up you know a really quick
digression
yeah one of that very same thing is what
basically caused the nobel prize to be
around
because uh nobel was known as
a weapons manufacturer uh what
nitroglycerin for
a producing propellant for all sorts of
weapons and he was one of the major
weapons manufacturers for world war one
and
he got i saw an obit calling him like
the merchant of death and so he's like
well
i need to change this and so he created
the nobel prize and now
we don't remember him as the merchant of
death but the guy who helps promote
the forward movement of science you know
that's really interesting
and i'm going to engage in a little
digression too so in
in my business ethics classes i think
it's peter drucker who came up with this
distinction
between different kinds of virtues
there's your resume virtues and eulogy
virtues he doesn't say obituary virtues
but it could be done with an obituary
too right
and and the idea is basically like your
resume virtues are the things that you
do to get you through the day or the
week or the month of the quarter and
they're
things that people you know praise you
for like oh they're resourceful they
show up on time you know they they don't
steal from the company coffers oh that's
very nice right
and then your eulogy virtues are what
you want people to really remember
you for after you're dead so really
after you're dead nobody cares if you
showed up on time
that's good that's good for you know
while you're employed
but you want to be remembered for these
other things you know
and i think it's kind of a cool cool
distinction and and if you did like if
you were brutally honest with yourself
and you read you you wrote your own
obituary i mean you could get other
people to be
brutally honest with about you too uh
maybe that would help to change people i
guess you know it's it's sort of like
what ebenezer screws is
scrooge is going through and um
christmas carol right right he gets to
see how how badly he screwed things up
and
ruined his relations and little tim dies
and
sees the open grave and then you know he
has a
hallelujah moment and he's like
christmas is here
let's get a goose so but the biggest one
there is
exactly yeah let's come back to the
stoic so yeah
so um like you were saying basic idea
is visualizing something it doesn't
necessarily have to be like
necessarily a visual image you could
imagine like what it's like to get
stabbed
you know or burned or anything like that
it could be tactile it could it could
also be about the feelings that you're
going to
encounter and um the idea is you take
something and and this is where it gets
in some of the questions we'll consider
later
it doesn't have to be something super
major right it could be
something fairly small to start with
like for example i have this
camera that i use for my filming and
what if i lost the battery
well then you know i wouldn't be able to
video recording wouldn't that be a
calamity
because then i couldn't get the videos
done that i need to do for my students
and that you can start spiraling right
and then you know my class will be
behind and then and then and then and
then and then right
so you can you can start out with with
imagining these things
and then you you just kind of do what
what what's different
between this what we're talking about
and
panicking or catastrophizing or
ruminating the first thing is to
realize that it's an indifferent that
your your happiness and your uh
equanimity or your even-mindedness or
even killedness
are not dependent upon these external
things
and then so if you say realize that what
if somebody
what if somebody doesn't feel that way
what if you know what if losing this
water bottle
is really going to screw up my day are
you saying
they are trying to do this technique are
they
yeah in the moment okay um
then the the idea is to like be
aware to uh
examine your mind state and why you
think that this thing
is actually of value so you have to
remind yourself right you got to do a
bit of
self-talk you might say or coaching
it could be helpful to have um you know
some stoic writings on the side
first times that you're doing it you
know yeah uh
i think there's quite a few examples of
marcus aurelius of doing exactly this
oh yeah good spot there are lots of
little
rather short ones you can find the ones
that reference this particular practice
and like oh yeah
do that and realize you know
do the deconstruction if you want or you
know yeah
wha what is this this bottle but a bit
of water and a bit of plastic and what
is plastic but
a a long dead tree and
and a bit of sun and uh you know and
yeah you know
is that thing actually of all that value
and a little bit of blue dye too to make
it oh yeah or whatever makes it blue i
don't know i don't know what makes it
blue
but yeah well you know so so that's
that's a good way of of talking about it
and
um you know it involves a few other
things
you can if you do feel like something is
bad
you know death for example i think a lot
of people consider that to be a bad
thing
you can you can think about well is this
really bad why do i think it's bad
you know instead of like just saying oh
well i know it's bad
i feel that it's bad you know you
interrogate those
those feelings while you're doing
negative visualization and
the big thing is the judgments that we
are automatically
associating with these things we have
these preconceived notions of
things being good or bad and these
things
can be interrogated and that that is
definitely the
the place of inquiry that you should be
asking like why am i feeling bad about
this situation
so let me ask you a question because
you've been doing this for quite a while
and
i i have two um and i think one of the
questions that would come up
pretty early for a lot of people would
be okay so i i
have this thing and it's kind of scaring
me or ticking me off or disturbing me in
some
way and i look at it and i'm like okay
well it's not
as bad as i'm making it out to be and i
realize that i've got
the reason why i'm viewing it as bad is
because i've got these thoughts that i'm
thinking about it
and i'm doing this kind of automatically
what if that person then says
but i can't stop thinking about it that
way or i can't help
but think about it that way what would
you say to them then
there's two parts of this question
because i know that there are
certain um mental conditions which
result in intrusive uh cons
consistently negative thoughts about
certain things yeah um
and for that i don't think that just
trying to think that away
is going to be uh all that successful
like you might need some outside help to
work through that or
potentially there is a chemical as
causing some of these things
outside of that of someone that is maybe
a little bit more neurotypical
then i would definitely say that
um you
could use uh some outside examples of
like journaling about why you think this
is bad
and try to i don't know investigate it
that way around it right yeah
yeah i mean when people have something
where they're like well this is bedrock
for me
um maybe it's not bedrock for you in
reality but it is right now
and so you got to just keep digging away
at it and then maybe
it won't change this time that you do it
but maybe 10 times down the line
you have an aha moment and you're like
oh wait a second i actually don't have
to think about it that way
i think habit plays a big role too you
know i i would
absolutely agree that
especially if you had a entire lifetime
of being told that this thing is a good
or a bad thing
it's going to take a lot of work to try
to reassociate those
judgments especially because a lot of
our judgments are not like
us consciously going through and like
okay i'm gonna add up all the goods and
bads about this or pros and cons of this
thing
and i'm gonna make a final judgment i do
or do not want this thing
i think that's completely right and i
think we also do
tend to have like thrust onto us the
idea
that our thoughts and our feelings just
are the way they are
and we're kind of stuck with them you
know and undoing that itself
is often it takes a lot of work
right and yeah like i i like to have the
different view of an emotion as emotion
is something that
happens kind of like a sneeze it is a
perfectly
valid thing it doesn't mean that you
have to
follow through in you know whatever that
uh you know emotion has presented you
i was laughing because i was thinking
about like a kleenex and sneezing into
something like that first sadness or
anger or joy
you know yeah i was like oh i i sneezed
anger and it's like oh no it's like
attacking me and it's
infecting my brain i now have to follow
it and go
yeah it can be contagious for other
people too right right
yeah i'm liking this metaphor a lot more
so actually that's a good place to talk
about emotions in this right and there's
two things i wanted to
bring out with respect to negative
visualization
one is that if you're doing it right it
should provoke some emotions
at least at first because that's why you
do it
right so what are the different emotions
anxiety and fear is a really big one for
it but i i think anger is another good
one as well if you're somebody who needs
to manage their anger you can do
negative visualization
shame or humiliation you know
embarrassment
aversion or disgust and then when i was
thinking about it i thought you know
well there's sadness and grief
to to consider but also boredom boredom
is an emotion right and
a lot of people can't stand being
bored or feeling like there's nothing
going on
and so you could imagine boring
situations
if that's really a problem for you and
then that would help you to deal with
them better
and then i thought well also desire you
know
if you think to yourself i have such a
hard time
controlling my sexual desire or my
desire for food or
desire for these these other things
maybe that's something to do negative
visualization with i haven't done that
myself
but i could see how somebody could and
so
when you're visualizing the thing you
think about the the disturbing factor
and you know emotions will be produced
so if you think about dying
and think about dying in a very vivid
way that probably should scare you
or it might make you angry too you know
or just sad
right um and and when you have one of
your
family members yeah well that's where
the grief i think could come up right
yeah but also fear you're right um
so when you when you picture that you'll
feel the emotion right and then what do
you do with that emotion
um you allow yourself to feel it
is there anything else that you do with
the emotion and negative visualization
uh and then you investigate it you know
you you
you realize that you can be okay with
the emotions as they arise
and realize that you they're not
a horse that you have to be uh tied to
that as long as you every time that that
emotion arises you can say okay
i'm feeling this this would if i
was not investigating it then i would
not
um then i would act in this way
should i actually act in this way and
try to decouple
that action from the experience of
having an emotion
so what is what does that do for us then
um
do we feel the emotion less over time
uh for for me specifically i would say
for most you know
if you are decoupling that judgment from
things that you
previously thought were bad then the
emotion tends to arise less especially
if it's like anger or sadness about the
loss of something
yeah so what else what else
happens in negative visualization i
think there's there's
a few other important components
you definitely become more resilient to
the you know the vicissitudes of life
or you know it's just the regular inter
ins and outs you know the easiest one is
uh probably just driving in traffic
that's one of the first ones that i
noticed
is like there's there's constant
jostling and go and bumping
or you know or close calls going on and
you just
uh if you can pull away that anger
component you can
much more easily deal with the day and
the
challenges that are put forth in front
of you driving can be scary too
yeah i remember as total you know
digression before they
changed all the highways here in
milwaukee
i was living over on farwell avenue and
i was working
at a place out in the suburbs so i had
to
get on to 43 and then go on to 94. and
the way things were set up at that
point in order to go the way that i was
going
i had to essentially every morning veer
across
three lanes of traffic in the space of a
mile
and this is like you know morning rush
hour traffic and i i wasn't
you know i was in my 20s so i wasn't as
an experienced a driver as i am now
where i
i could probably like do that while
drinking my coffee and stuff but
um i found it kind of scary when i was
doing that you know
and i i i didn't have stoicism as a help
i mean i could have like done some
visualization
things in the in the morning because
every morning i was getting up and i
fortunately the job didn't last that
long because it was a mortgage company
and they changed the interest rates and
they went under i was so happy that they
that the
company failed it was a temp job and and
but i would i would get in my car and
i'd be like dreading
this terrible interchange
that i would have to make every morning
so are you i guess you're you have some
gratitude you don't have that job
anywhere and
that's also true negative visualization
providing i would have helped if i would
have done that yeah
yeah and that the negative visualization
provides that
you know a bit of sense of gratitude for
the reality of things are
and yeah if we do it right it can help
we don't have to like completely
eliminate emotion we could replace
emotions that we don't want to feel with
emotions that we
we do want to feel it could be gratitude
it could be joy i think as well right
right like i'm joyful that i
did not get angry at the situation that
used to be causing me so much anger or
is fear so that that actually brings us
to another aspect
of what happens when you're doing
negative visualization
and the stomachs talk about this quite a
lot
we you know we experience our emotion we
visualize something we also
discover or we could like maybe force
ourselves to think about
the resources that we have to deal with
the thing at hand
you know maybe we can't turn it off and
realize that
people cutting us off in traffic isn't
them you know
being jerks to us uh they're they're
just doing what they they
they do and it's it's you know maybe we
can't stop
like that anger response but we can at
least figure out what resources we have
to deal with it
you know like we can say well i don't
have to honk my horn at that that jerk
or try to cut him off or anything like
that
or if we're thinking about the fear of
death you know maybe
maybe we're still gonna view death as a
bad thing
and um you know feel bad about it in
some way
but we don't have to feel too bad about
it we don't have to dwell on it
we could think about do i have the
resources if if i'm going to
face i don't know getting sick and dying
i just turned 50 so
you know maybe 51 is all i get who knows
right um if i imagine that to myself i
could think about well could i
could i deal with that i mean my dad did
he died when he was 36
in a hospital and he seemed to have had
a pretty
decent death as they say um
reminds me of people who when faced with
large
challenges um will shrink away from
those
large challenges and focus on things
that are mundane
and easily controllable like choosing
the the color of the carpet in their
apartment
instead of you know uh a death of the
family or
like a big financial melody
yeah what do you think about that well i
think that
doing um negative visualizations allows
us
to uh put these things into the the
categories of indifference
which allows us to even when things are
going
incredibly badly actually be more
present
and make the best decisions instead
of poor decisions so for example um
i was an absolute wreck when my father
died
and i was kind of useless in in
helping finish up the funeral plans
and thank gosh for my brother to
come in and was able to help me out with
that because i
was in in such a state that i was
failing at this
process that i really needed to get done
yeah i
i mean i had something similar happen
when my mom died
i was 29 and my sister was 27 and
pregnant
so you know we had to handle all this
stuff and and she was just not
you know not up to it you know and there
it was such a mess
all these different things that had to
be found and
dealt with and you know a lot of these
experiences that we have
it's the first time around we're doing
it right right
yeah it was i was 24
i think wow when my father died and so
yeah yeah that's that's even tougher
you know i i had a student um
in one of the places where i taught this
was several years ago
and she came up to me about halfway
through the semester
and she she was only i think 20 or so
and she she was apologizing for
having been absent a couple times and
she said
you know i'm really sorry i'm going to
get caught back up on work
but we had a death in the family and
as i asked her more questions i found
out it was her mother who died and
her mother was a single parent and
it was just her and a younger brother
and
um like a grandfather who had to be
taken care of as well
and so as a as a 20 year old she was
dealing with with you know like keeping
the household together and paying the
bills and
figuring out how to get her mom buried
and all that and i was like wow that's
you know i mean i i tried reaching out
to her she
she didn't finish the class of course
and i was not surprised at all because
uh
that's that's so such a difficult
situation yeah
and you know not finishing a class not a
big deal at that
you know fortunately it was it was at a
place where the classes weren't that
expensive
so what are some of the the problems
that can arise with this practice
so this is where it gets really
interesting i think a lot of people
out there especially in the sort of you
know let's popularize stoicism
kind of kind of world they look at this
as a magic bullet that's good for
everybody in every situation
it's not you know as you were pointing
out people who
are overcome by compulsive thoughts
maybe negative visualization if if
you're going to like you know visualize
something and it's going to be a trigger
and you're going to go down this spiral
maybe don't do negative visualization
then
maybe do other things right or at least
not by yourself i have someone there to
help you talk through that
right maybe maybe we need something like
a coach or a community
or we we do it as groups together
um you know i think some people
slit some people don't understand the
difference between negative
visualization
where you're actually trying to work on
stuff and just rumination
where you're just kind of circling
around a thought the stoics are not
saying
make yourself feel like crap for the
sake of feeling like crap
and maybe some people use it in order to
be kind of ascetic
and and you know self-flagellate
as well and i don't think the stoics
would like that
um what are some other some other issues
uh especially if you have um some like
ptsd
type things that if you bring this up
they could really tap into
things that you'd need you know uh
a much stronger guide you know therapy
to
start approaching yeah yeah uh
and which isn't to say that somebody
with trauma couldn't do any negative
visualization
but it wouldn't be prudent to do it
wouldn't be prudent to try to like think
that you're being courageous by
taking you know head-on whatever it was
that traumatized you
and then like i'll do some negative
visualization about that maybe maybe
instead you do it with
you know i don't know public speaking or
uh the meal that you're making not
turning out well or something where
there's
much lower stakes right and
the whole idea is to kind of investigate
our judgments about
these things and if you can't get to the
place where you're
able to investigate then this is not
going to actually help you
yeah another thing that i think can be a
problem
is thinking that because you've done
some negative visualization exercises
now you're ready to walk into the
situation whatever it's been that you've
been prepping for
and you're going to be totally a-ok it's
sort of like you know in martial arts
doing a bunch of forms and a little bit
of sparring with people
and then you know walking across the
street to the bar and being like all
right who wants to fight
you know that's that's the best way to
do things
it reminds me of the uh the map is not
the terrain
oh right right yeah from the um
[Music]
uh what there was a movement that talks
about that all the time and they're
still around in new york
um there was a guy hayakawa who was
associated with them
uh it was a linguists who were linguists
and psychologists who'd constantly talk
about that
so but the the basic idea here is that
that's what it was okay yeah i'm not
familiar
but the the idea is a useful idea
which is that you know a map is
a lossy version of the reality that
you're living
in and so anytime that we are
visualizing things we
will there's we can't visualize every
different
permutation and there's the wife is
going to throw something at us
and it's it's not going to always work
but it's
better than doing nothing at all true
yeah and so i think that's kind of a
good segue into talking about
how how do you actually do this
you know should one have like a
particular time of the day to do
negative visualization
or you know yeah i think it's easy to
either set up morning or night to i i'd
actually say morning is probably really
good because you can think of like
because you're like prepping for the day
okay okay
i can think of like okay there's gonna
be a whole bunch of
uh annoying people on the road um and
then i'm gonna go into work and i've
gotta
i'm gonna have all these co-workers that
like maybe are jostling for permission
a position to you know get a better
promotion over me and so they
they might be you know backstabbing and
whatnot and
uh and maybe my you know just present it
as
if your like boss hates you and all you
got a rough job
yeah but that's the whole point of
negative visualization
yeah that you know once you actually go
there you're
uh if you don't have these things
then your better day is already better
than what you were
expecting it to be as well as
if these things do happen you have at
least
some work towards dealing with them in a
more
calm and forward moving way yeah
and i think sometimes maybe if you know
you're
about to go into something that's going
to be difficult for you
you could do negative visualization like
you take five minutes and
you know you don't go to the meeting
right away and this is so
we wanted to talk about a few examples
of this i had a client
who was a really high performer he was
a cio of a major corporation
and he would go into these high pressure
meetings
and he he wasn't the normal anger
management kind of person that i work
with where we have to teach them like
not to blow up at people
and not to like you know blame everybody
else for the anger he
he really had it put together but what
he found is that
in these situations they'd all kind of
poke at each other and he'd get a little
bit
he'd get angry not so angry like he'd
like you know slam his hand down or
something like that but it was enough to
like make him lose his edge because
anger makes you a little bit
blinded and he didn't want to do that so
i suggested well let's let's
you know how about before you go into
the meeting you take three minutes and
you do some negative visualization
you think about how this this guy in
particular is probably going to try to
get you ticked off
and how you're going to respond to that
you know and he found it was very
helpful for him
what are some other examples that we uh
relationships between
two individuals and one wanting
on the other one to do something for the
other but are
maybe remiss to actually ask them and
then they get angry when they don't do
things
difficult conversations right
everybody's got some
some meetings or conversations they're
not looking forward to
mm-hmm when i was i'll tell you
something kind of this is kind of uh
funny to talk about at this point in
time you'd never guess this from today
when i was in in high school my freshman
year
i was so shy when it came to
um the opposite sex that i had a hard
time calling girls on the phone
oh yeah yeah i mean you'd have to like
steal myself to do it
you know what's what's so scary about
that right well
you're feeling that fear and anxiety
from that exactly and there's so many
other people who do that and it could be
like you know
not just relationships it could be like
well there's this um
this pressing business thing that i need
to take care of but i don't know if i
want to send this email or not
and then you don't send the email and
now it's like a week later and you're
like
well i'd better write a longer email you
know to explain why i didn't email right
away and then you don't do that and it
gets
it gets to be like this big thing right
and then what do you do
you just bury it
or like uh grief or potential grief of
like you've got like a
older relative that that's a good one
yeah and you're like
i really need to call or i need to go
visit but you're you're so like worried
about like what it's gonna feel like
when they actually die
that your entire perception of their
interaction with them
is always in this like pre-death stage
instead of actually enjoying the life of
the person
when you can enjoy it that is a big
problem you're right a negative
visualization i think could actually
help out quite a bit with that and in a
way
it makes you able to be you know
we talk about the stoic virtues right
justice prudence courage
temperance it makes you able to be a
justice person in the sense of being
able to give other people
what they deserve you know your aged
relative
um you know what they don't deserve is
you bringing all your hang-ups
that get in the way of actually having a
human interaction with them you know
right just want somebody to be nice and
visit them so
and i'd even say it's even greater if
it's like you have a
sick and dying child like
that's right yeah that's even like at
least
the the person that is old kind of has a
better ability to realize
they're at the end of their life whereas
that of
a child would have a much more difficult
time understanding what is happening
you know it's interesting too i mean
this could be used for parents who are
dealing with
things that they kind of feel you know
like when they have to give the talk
about sex to their kids right
you know my mom was so embarrassed that
she she actually uh
she she just like buy books and slip
them into my bookshelf
like you know i was supposed to find
them and think like i'd put them there
or something
why does the same thing happen oh really
that's so funny
but i mean you know if you think about
it that's that's not a very effective
mode for for dealing with this stuff
that you really is very important
and you need to deal with you know and
so it could be that or it could be
finances or it could be like
i don't know al all sorts of other
things you know
in order to be there for your kids maybe
negative visualization is something
you'd want to be able to do or if
they're getting bullied
and you know you're going to actually go
and talk to the parent of the
kid who's doing the bullying odds are
that parent is probably a jerk
you know so it's not going to be a
pleasant conversation so you maybe do
some negative visualization before that
too
right also i love you mom
[Laughter]
so i did want to talk we were going to
talk a little bit about positive
visualization
and so we should talk very briefly about
the epicureans the epicureans are a
different school than the stoics
and they don't do they would actually
say it's bad to do
negative visualization because the
epicureans think that a pleasant life
is is what you want so why would you
subject yourself to these negative
emotions
instead you should think about happy
things things that
you enjoyed and this is a way to
actually get more pleasure out of a
situation so imagine like
you had a candy bar all the candy bar
was so good but it's in the past well
bring it
in your memory into the present and
think about how great that candy bar was
may be tough to do with a candy bar
maybe you could do it with a concert
you know there you go or a relationship
or something like that and that that way
you can have a more pleasant life
and when i was thinking about this i
thought well i mean do the stoics have
anything like that and i think yeah
actually they do they have some positive
visualization things
um epictetus at one point he's talking
about
you know you're going to try to resist
some pleasure
not giving into it think about how good
you're going to feel
down the line having resisted it
you know how much better off you're
going to be right well i think that's a
kind of pause
positive visualization exercise right
as well as yeah the progress in
changing your values or you're like oh i
realized that
i got angry at this thing and and maybe
uh
in the future i won't be i won't like
you know
go off the rails on on the situation
that is constantly
you know uh kicking me in the butt and
like
putting me down like if i'm angry at
work and then
no one wants to actually work with me uh
that's that anger is causing me
a negative outcome that if i can figure
out how not to get angry then i can
maybe have some positive outcomes from
doing things a little bit more
virtuously
yeah and so do you think that's the sort
of thing that maybe a person should
also do like once a day or at
certain given times like sort of a
thinking about how how they're going to
make progress or
where is that is that sort of like doing
wishful thinking
i i think if you're going to do it
regularly
the period must be much larger
if you're doing that daily i think it's
not going to be particularly useful
because you're
you're anticipating something and
uh like they say there's there's studies
about saying that you have less
um motivation to do something once
you've told other people to do it
and so you're telling yourself that
you're gonna do this thing and it's
gonna be great
and then you have maybe less motivation
to actually do the negative
visualizations itself
okay yeah that makes that makes a lot of
sense
and one thing you could potentially do
if you want to take the negative
visualization to like even a a greater
level
is you could actually put yourself in
situations that
would have made you feel uh negatively
in other ways
and so um for example uh get a onesie
and walk through a mall could be
something of like
i don't care what i look like and i
don't care how people are reacting to me
and you can visualize that but there's
another thing of actually experiencing
putting yourself in that particular
situation
yeah that that's like that's a great one
or what is that thing that you could buy
on tv the snuggly
it's basically like a blanket and uh and
a onesie at the same time
snuggy yeah
we we had a few questions that we we
found about
this i think maybe we'll probably unless
we blow through them real quick we'll
probably only have time for for one
so um pick your point which one should
we take
the second one okay do you want to read
it or you want me to uh
sure so we're thinking about bad things
before they happen
and if they do how situations could go
wrong
the worst outcome given circumstances
etc
all for the purpose of better preparing
ourselves
i believe i understand the motivation
behind the teaching if i'm incorrect in
my understanding
thus far please let me know when i lose
the value
in the idea where i lose value in the
idea is
that there is an unspoken assumption
that uh
what could happen whatever it may be is
bad
forget not that it is this simple
philosophy telling us to
love our fates or more fote which is
teaching
i have come to really which is the
teaching i've come to really appreciate
we are assuming that this bad thing we
are preparing for
is actually bad and are trying to fix
the problem
when it may not necessarily be bad at
all
a picture a picture a situation of two
stoics talking
one picturing what could go wrong and
the other telling him that whatever will
happen
can only be dealt with when it is in the
present moment
and dealt with improper using the stoic
teachings
let me clarify do not deep down
believe that there is a place for
premeditato malorum in daily life
i just need help finding it
if it does have a place in my daily life
yeah so what do you make of this uh
it seems like he's he's
missing this really core part that
um it's not that where you're
dealing with it as it doesn't matter
because it's not in the present moment
it's that it is most likely indifferent
and it's the the judgment that he's not
actually making here
um and it's not a a temporal position
yeah i i think that there's maybe a
little bit
too much stress late on when especially
when it comes to popularizing stoicism
about like being in the moment man
you know it's kind of kind of new agey
sort of stuff when really what we're
supposed to have is like an integrated
presence that's connected with the
future that we're you know
looking towards and getting ready to
deal with
and a past that actually kind of makes
sense um
but i think there's something else in
here too so i i i read this
as this person is saying um
we don't need to do any sort of negative
visualization or pre-meditation while
orem
because the things aren't actually bad
according to stoicism
and that's that's correct you know i
mean stoics are saying that a lot of
these things like
you know for example losing a job right
if i lose my job i'm not going to have
any money
the stoics would say okay that's a
that's an indifferent that's a preferred
indifferent but it is still an
indifferent
it doesn't make you a bad person to lose
your job it doesn't make you a good
person to have your job
but you know what you do with your job
obviously does
does matter quite a bit and i think the
mistake that's that's made here
is not realizing that the reason why we
need to do negative visualization
is because even if we've heard this
stoic doctrine about the indifference
that doesn't mean that we actually
believe it and that's part of how
screwed up we are
you know we think that things that
aren't bad are
are actually bad i think we're getting
low on
on time um so we got to bring this to a
close
i just want to bring in one last thing
about belief and i
i um come to the conclusion that we do
not
choose our beliefs that i can't like
believe that i am
uh i don't know a unicorn uh i have to
come to these conclusions and
only once we are presented with enough
evidence that this is not the way
something is
do we then change our beliefs well
that's that's good to close on i i think
we can skip the
quote and just say yep thanks everybody
for listening
thank you
[Music]